there's something else we've been
waiting to see Clay Aiken remember him
and Moo burn stuttered
reunited
get ready for the American Idol alums to
bring Christmas to Broadway I would stop
singing for about five years had moved
into doing other things and I wouldn't
saw Ruben do a show back in April and I
left that show that night and told my
manager listen I'm ready to sing again
everyone will do it with me 40 year old
Ruben and 39 year-old clay re teaming up
for the Broadway extravaganza title
ruben enclave's first annual christmas
carol' family fun pageant spectacular
reunion show
[Music]
you are a classic you're old enough now
to be a classic look at your hair in
2003 40 million people watched Rubin win
Idol with clay as the runner-up Rubens
play unsuccessfully ran for Congress in
North Carolina in 2014 the Christmas
show was his idea for the perfect
comeback he's my brother and I really
love singing with him and I was just
glad that he was up to him because you
know he went and did his you know
political stent and left us in the music
world to to cry without him and now he's
back the teddy bear I know I don't know
I miss him
[Music]